bem eu vou contar a história de uma casa
e da relação minha com essa casa essa
casa que se chama casa grande é uma casa
do século 17
do início do ciclo do couro quando é o o
governador da bahia tomé de souza
começou é é a o ciclo do couro no
nordeste junto com garcía da vida então
foi feita à casa da torre no litoral
baiano eo gado entrou no sertão e essa
casa ela chegou no ano de 1932 é na
minha família nas mãos do meu avô então
em 92
eu resolvi e restaurar essa essa casa e
à minha volta à nova olinda que eu
passei um tempo fora do ceará foi
justamente quando eu era criança é em
nova olinda tinha uma cabocla que
contava as lendas cariri em torno da
chapada do araripe a chapada do araripe
ela é um é um manancial de lenda
desde 900 mil anos porque um reserva
fosse livro é uma história é uma parte
da história do planeta no cariri foi um
do surgiu as primeiras flores do planeta
para quem não sabe através de resquícios
fósseis que tem hoje em um museu de
paleontologia de santana e nova olinda
não resolvemos
é eu eu tenho a minha companheira
roseane que a arqueóloga a gente começou
a fazer pesquisas sobre essas lendas da
mitologia do cariri e essas lendas nós
fomos encontrando cavernas nós fomos em
com cupim pintura rupestre
nós fomos encontrando é sítio lítico
city cerâmico que contava a história da
memória do homem no local
então a gente começou a recolher
material pra compor músicas que falavam
de mitologia
circular pelo ceste vários brasileiros e
fazer espetáculos contando desta cultura
antes da colonização européia aqui no
brasil então e nós começamos o projeto
de restauração a casa estava lá
nós aproveitamos todo o material que
estava na casa de tijolo que ainda tinha
e naná de munição aline de paredes que
caíram então a gente chamou os pedreiros
locais que já tinha é de ribadu casa
antiga que já tinha trabalhado com
demolições de casas antigas da época e
nós chamamos essas pessoas da cidade
chamamos também a população fazendo um
diálogo com eles é pra saber de quando
aquela casa estava como era que era a
casa como era pintada e quando foi de 92
nós inauguramos a casa quando nós
inauguramos a casa a gente pensou isso
dentro da casa tinha um memorial do
homem kariri contando a história
mitológica e arqueológico desse povo que
está em torno da chapada do araripe é
nós já temos datações de a 1200 anos
atrás dos 1200 anos dodô presente nós já
tínhamos o homem em torno da chapada do
araripe ali era um verdadeiro
entroncamento humano porque as
escavações que a gente tem feito lá no
cariri tem mostrado que tem passado o
povo tupi guarani era um ponto desse de
força com uma chapada dos guimarães com
uma chapada diamantina faz parte do
terreiro alto do mundo então nesse local
a gente botou esse museu e memorial do
homem kariri com fotografia sobre essas
áreas e e as lendas e as crianças
começaram da cidade começaram a chegar
chegar para jogar de bila para brincar
no terreiro da casa e aos poucos essas
crianças elas foram entrando é na casa
ea gente começou a detectar que eles
explicavam aquilo para os turistas às
pessoas que os visitantes
aquilo que eles ouviam a gente
explicando então o que a gente fez as
crianças brincando no terreiro as
crianças explicando aquilo ali sobre a
arqueologia sobre mitologia contando as
lendas que eles ouviam a gente contar
pra quem visitava a casa então a gente
começou a potencializar isso começou a
pegar essas crianças e aprofundar mais
aquele assunto com elas sobre é é a
entre o lúdico que eram as brincadeiras
populares é que tenhamos no sertão e a
história para a história daquele homem é
na região então aos poucos essas
crianças elas foram se destacando elas
foram assumindo é funções na própria
casa então nós começamos a denominar
para essas crianças é funções então as
primeiras funções que nós tivemos foi
diretor de cultura para aquela criança
que a gente via que tinha uma liderança
diante dos outros de de gerenciar as
brincadeiras o joguinho sempre fazia
campeonato de peão de pipa de papagaio
né desses jogos que era feito na rua né
em nova olinda ea gente começou a fazer
entregar e se essas vamos assim
denominada funções para ele então
diretor de cultura diretor de pesquisa
para aquele que tinha é que despertou de
explicar o museu que estava dentro da
casa e diretor de manutenção para aquele
que chegava sempre que chegava na casa
grande de manhãzinha a preocupação dele
era com aspecto de limpeza da casa e um
lugar onde as crianças brincar o terrier
inter lhe pinto então a gente criou o
diretor de cultura o de pesquisa e o
diretor de manutenção e aí essas
crianças elas começaram a trazer outras
crianças
e aí foram criando funções cargos para
eles mesmo então diretor de pesquisa e
criou auxiliar de pesquisa e criou o
recepcionista que já passou já
terceirizou
já terceirizou aquilo que ele iniciou né
e tem um enfarto bem interessante nisso
é que uma vez 11 uma criança chegou e
notou que estava jogando papel dentro
das do jarro de planta ele disse eu
quero ser diretor dos papelzinho ele
está bom e vai ser diretor do papel zin
então um dia ele chegou pra mim depois
de uma semana sem diretor do papel zin
ele disse pra mim olha o seguinte eu não
quero ser mais diretores papelzinho que
eu cansei
depois você está exonerado aí ele saiu
pra casa feliz que ganhou aquela outra
função muito mais e mais difícil de
pronunciar que o diretor do papel zinho
né
exonerado era um cargo internacional o
primeiro carro internacional da casa
grande
nós tivemos passamos na fundação é
quatro anos sem nenhum recurso era a
casa grande era mantido por 200 reais
que era 100 reais pra energia e sempre
uma pessoa que morava em frente fica
vendo a casa e olhando por menino
apartar briga como se diz né
e aí esse e se esses meninos lá na casa
grande e se esse era o dinheiro da nossa
manutenção e aí eu disse olha o menino a
vocês não se preocupe não tem um
convênio onde não tem um convênio aí
demorou demorou demorou depois quatro
anos cheguei lá em casa na casa grande e
um gato na casa
aí eu só vi um menino correndo atrás
dele com vincos primeiro convênio nós um
gato né
então nós temos seis áreas na fundação
essas áreas elas são áreas ligadas ao
que a casa grande é trabalha é que é
artis né e eac de comunicação nós temos
dentro da escola de comunicação da
menina do sertão ali tanto eles têm a
bandinha de lata que a iniciação musical
como também eles têm é uma uma tv eles
têm uma rádio comunitária então lá
dentro desse espaço neste entre seis
áreas abrangem
isso aí abrange a parte de the arts é
meio ambiente
nós temos também a área de meio ambiente
lá na fundação a quem está passando
então a meio ambiente
nós temos é a parte ligada ao património
histórico que essa da museologia na
fundação
nós temos também é depois dessa parte de
das seis áreas da fundação que é meio
ambiente que é a arte que é patrimônio
histórico a gente tem os programas da
fundação e nos programas da fundação
nós temos o primeiro programa hoje a
fundação tem o primeiro programa que é
de educação infantil esse programa de
educação infantil é um programa que o
menino entra na fundação pra ver pra
ouvir então nós temos um dever de teca
com mais de 3.500 títulos de cinema que
os meninos vão assistir desde os swells
akira kurosawa fellini então a gente
trabalha as crianças pela qualidade do
que eles vêem futebol honra né
então essa é uma das áreas da fundação
aí né então tem futebol aí você vê a
parte de turismo meio ambiente e esses
laboratórios de conteúdo que estou
falando só agora todo o conteúdo e manda
ele adquire esse conteúdo é a nossa
preocupação é com a qualidade daquilo
que ele está vendo nós temos uma
gibiteca com mais de 1500 gibbs também é
por ao topo desenhista para que eles
possam ter acesso àquele tipo de
comunicação uma discoteca com um acervo
bem bond vinil e também de música de
qualidade na rádio da casa grande é como
se fosse uma universidade da boa música
então eles vão tocar para a comunidade
aquele vão tocar para a comunidade
aquela aquela aquele repertório musical
e ao mesmo tempo vão ver a poesia
ver é os arranjos musicais ea partir daí
eles começam também a tocar ea iniciação
musical esperança bandinha de lata que
circula se chama os cabinha porque aqui
no nordeste do brasil se chama caminha
criança o caminho caminho então e é uma
denominação de criança
então o programa os cinco programas da
fundação casa grande é o de educação
infantil neste educação infantil esse
dever de poder sentir a qualidade é uma
iniciação à qualidade na fundação
depois desse programa nós temos as
crianças elas têm um programa de
empreendedor profissionalização eles
passam a pegar os equipamentos passam a
junto com essa é como manuseio e pegado
os equipamentos eles começam a se
aprofundar em profissionalização
depois do programa de profissionalização
nós temos um programa de empreendedor
juvenil em um deles já vi o cnpj dele já
vai trabalhar e começará a sentir o que
é ser um profissional um programa que
nós temos também que o programa dê de
geração de renda familiar do programação
na programação de no programa de geração
de renda familiar
a gente já envolve os pais existem
pousadas domiciliares existem
restaurantes e aí toda essa parte do
receptivo turístico da fundação é feita
pelos pais então as pessoas vão buscar
no aeroporto tem agência dele viagem que
vão buscar no aeroporto e os pais têm
essas pousadas domiciliares que nessas
pousadas domiciliares
eles recebem os turistas que vêm do
brasil e de fora do brasil e nós temos
também em programa de gestão da própria
instituição esse programa toda parte de
manutenção da fundação a fundação custa
48 mil reais por ano custa 4 mil por mês
e esses quatro mil é gerenciado um mês é
gerenciado por eles
a gente chega a economizar por ano de 7
a 8 mil
por ano todos feitos compartilhado com
as crianças porque foram eles quem
trouxer isso então eles administram
desde a parte de compra de especificação
de qual é o material que nós devemos
comprar é todo feito por eles
então esse tipo de gestão hoje um é é um
modelo de gestão é um modelo que hoje a
gente é chamado por vários países para
mostrar isso
nesse trabalho de gestão e de um produto
cultural feito em conjunto com a
comunidade
háháhá a ré descoberta da comunidade
feita em conjunto principalmente com as
crianças
hoje as crianças ela já já já são é quem
gerencia a mesma fundação nem e isso tem
gerado prêmios para a fundação os nossos
vamos ver se os que a gente chama de
melhores parceiros são os amigos que a
gente tem espalhado pelo mundo inteiro
então a gente chega a fazer eventos na
fundação internacional com 50 mil reais
porque essas pessoas tão espalhada pelo
mundo e essas pessoas têm contribuído
principalmente como voluntário pra ea
casa grande capacitar as crianças é a
nossa pedagogia a pedagogia da fundação
casa grande é uma vez chegar para mim
isto é pedagogia que vocês têm aqui na
casa grande e quando você vê aí ele
disse eu vejo não sei quem é esse fulano
de tal que o povo é saber que só nessa
mulher um cara dele aí ele conhece aí né
ai chega outros é essa aí né a um dia de
tanto dizer pedagógico povo dizia de
cópia da guia que sua mãe lhe criou eu
não sabia dirigir sábado né então a
pedagogia da casa grande a pedagogia do
amor é a pedagogia da gente acompanhar
toda a história de uma pessoa né e
desenvolveu humanidade
o o o das coisas que chamam a atenção da
prefeitura de toronto sobre esse
trabalho feito na casa grande é que o
resultado nossa alegria é carinho é amor
então isso que muitas vezes as pessoas
estão atrás de quantitativos e eu
procuro sempre falar com os meninos
eu não quero vocês primeiro em nada
não quero eu quero vocês no meio da fila
que quem está no meio da fila ver quem
está atrás de quem está na frente
então a gente crescer junto com a nossa
comunidade porque uma das coisas que o
mundo está mais precisando é de quem
cresça junto com sua comunidade
ele não ficar na frente e os outros
atrás então a gente precisa junto então
eu quando era criança eu pensava quando
eu ficar grande eu tiver dinheiro eu vou
pegar e vou construir 14 de brinquedo
pra mim vai ter um dia que não quer
saber minha mulher menin
eu quero saber do quarto de brinquedos
aquele forte apache que tem rotali bater
essas coisas que aquele carrinho é meu
brinquedo é o seguinte
ae depois de muitos anos aí a casa
grande que é meu quarto de brincar eu
brinco com as crianças da cidade e tenho
a satisfação de ter tirado o tapete na
minha vida um tempo os ontem divisão
entre a adolescência infância e adulto e
se deus quiser chegar na fala de velho
né
então eu penso assim é que coisa boa né
é quem faz o que gosta de coisa boa é
quem é tem nem assim a oportunidade de
viver a infância uma vida inteira com
esses meninos eu estou tendo essa
oportunidade são os grandes parceiros
nós grato